live with a Bible in one hand at a
newspaper in the other this is the
advice attributed to theologian Karl
Bart they do not have equal weight for
Bart unless of course you have the full
Sunday Times the Bible is weightier Bart
would suggest to interpret the newspaper
through the lens of the Bible but
nonetheless live your life with the
Bible in one hand in the newspaper in
the other and so this morning with a
Bible in one hand we are given two
parables the parable of the lost sheep
the story of that one sheep who
rebellious Lee wanders off and the Good
Shepherd who seeks after that sheep and
brings it back home and the parable of
the lost coin the woman scours her
entire house weeping every corner and
finally finds it with the newspaper in
the other hand we read about floods and
fire child soldiers and investment
bankers Fashion Week and unemployment we
read that it has been a very rough week
for our Muslim neighbors with someone
threatening to burn the quran and the
end of the holy month of ramadan and the
anniversary of September 11 2001 all
overlapping with what is usually a
joyous celebration this weekend of Eid
outfitter we read in these pages and we
see in the lives of our neighbors that
we are on tender ground this week also
marked the Jewish holy days of Rosh
Hashanah the Jewish New Year a time to
mark a new beginning but also a time to
look back at what has been especially in
these liminal days now leading up to yom
kippur a time for atonement the time for
repentance and so are Jewish and Muslim
neighbors are in a season of
contemplation diligent prayer repentance
and I'm afraid that we or at least I am
often not so good
that yet with these parables in one hand
and the newspaper in the other the need
for Christians to take time for
examination and repentance seems very
clear you see when I hear the parable of
the lost sheep I am pretty sure the lost
sheep is somebody else someone I know
who is wandered far away from God
someone whose behavior I dislike someone
may be like that pastor in florida
threatening to burn the quran but then I
stop and think I don't want him in my
flock he can't be the one Jesus would be
seeking maybe someone like him but less
evil someone who just wanders away but
not me I'm not the lost sheep if I were
Sharon might fire me my bishop would be
really upset my congregation would stop
listening yet this parable defines the
lost sheep as a sinner and I am
certainly not exempt from sin if the 99
sheep represent those in need of no
repentance well if I'm honest I'm a lost
sheep and aren't we all Martin Luther
was big on paradox and one of the most
essential for him was the dual reality
for each of us as saint and sinner we
are always partially with the 99 sheep
with our lives in order living in
harmony making the Angels proud and we
are always partially that one sheep who
has wandered into the wilderness the
part of ourselves that Jesus is still
seeking to transform this is the paradox
we can take with us into reading the
newspaper or wandering the streets of
New Haven many times this week I was
tempted to yell at the TV when threats
of violence or the sensational ization
of opposing opinions just really got on
my nerves but the parable of the lost
sheep asks us to think carefully about
our own assumptions the walls and our
heads and hearts the ignorance that not
only lives in a lone voice crying out
for violence but also deep within my own
bones it is tempting to distance
ourselves from what others do in the
name of Jesus we do not want to be
lumped together with the very few
radical Christians perpetuating hate but
let's be honest about our own
shortcomings to our their small ways we
have let such such acts happen through
our stunned silence do we ever assume
the radical acts of a few represent the
whole group the parable of the lost
sheep calls for deep humility because
the second we assume we are safe in the
99 with our lives completely in order we
have darted back out into the wilderness
of pride yet again the second we think
we are the good shepherd with the task
of seeking the lost we must also
remember we are a sheep draped over the
shoulders of the shepherd who sought us
out and is carrying us home even now as
a freshman in college I was part of a
wonderful christian fellowship group we
met weekly for singing in Bible study we
became fast friends was a tight group
this group saved me when my roommate was
driving me crazy when basketball was
exhausting me but I remember a
particular moment when one of my
basketball teammates also a Christian
said she could never come to that group
she assumed there would be no room for
her everyone already knew each other so
well they all spoke the same language
she had a lot of questions about God and
assumed they would not be welcome in
that group whether or not these things
were actually true she had experienced
them to be true and she really got me
thinking at I know kind of tight knit
community is what we're all seeking in a
church or a Bible study or a fellowship
or prayer group these are our homes away
from home
our ports in the storm they become our
families but the flip side of being part
of that tight knit group meant that I
had helped my teammate get the
impression that she was the one and we
were the 99 there wasn't room for her
that we were the saints and she was the
sinner I ended up transitioning to into
other campus ministries during my time
in college but in retrospect I actually
regret not talking to that group's
leaders a little bit I regret not asking
some hard questions I regret not looking
around and asking is everyone here or is
anyone left out if one feels excluded we
are not whole we cannot be all things to
all people but are we really reflecting
God's open welcome of course we don't
have that completely figured out here at
the university church either you'll see
a long statement of welcome in your blue
bulletin inserts but we can never fully
reflect the extravagance of God's
welcome we'll just keep trying but
sometimes we assume you're all familiar
with liturgical language or even know
what the word liturgical means sometimes
we assume that everyone can read music
as well as the choir and yet being asked
to sing in public might be the strangest
thing you've been ever asked to do this
is a time to remember that it is God's
welcome that it is Christ persistent
searching for us until the circle is
complete that we are trying to reflect
we do not create it we just try to
reflect it welcoming one another is an
ongoing task one way we try to reflect
this is by inviting everyone to take
part in this church however they like as
we recognized leaders and commissioned
deacons this morning remember these are
not exclusive groups of chosen ones but
instead they recommend they represent
the larger whole of our congregation
because every single one of you here
today even if this is your first time he
you are an important an integral part of
this community in another way we try to
reflect God's welcome is by trying to be
good neighbors to our Jewish and Muslim
and Buddhist and atheist friends as well
as fellow Christians with whom we might
have some significant disagreements and
nonetheless they are our neighbors in
the parable of the lost coin the woman
has 10 coins and loses just one but if
we lost ten percent of our treasures we
would work really hard to recover them
if ten percent of our neighbors are
being persecuted it's time to speak up
if ten percent of more more of the
world's population is starving we to
hunger for justice at the heart of both
of these parables we remember there is
inherent value in every part of the
whole and so the woman picks up her
broom and cleans every inch of her
humble home looking desperately for that
lost coin and then the coin is found
what was lost is now returned again the
neighbor facing hostility knows she has
an ally the student questioning knows he
has a place here God is like the woman
sweeping dust out of the corners of our
lives making us new gathering in what
was lost we are the coin in God's hand a
treasured life yet there are other coins
as part of this collective treasure
coins made up of our neighbors even
those with whom we disagree those who
help us remember who we are being in a
diverse multi-faith community might be a
new thing for many of you it was for me
at various points in my life but at
least for me it has helped to strengthen
my Christian faith and it has also
increased my respect for
people who believe other things because
we need each other remember Carl Bart's
invitation to have a Bible in one hand
and the newspaper in the other and to
interpret news headlines in light of the
Bible and so we remember that inside
these troubling news stories are human
beings treasured coins in the hands of
God that when everything around us seems
like it's falling apart God the Good
Shepherd seeks us out and brings us home
God transform us the saintly and not so
saintly parts of our lives lead us into
repentance lead us into freedom thank
you for seeking us and rejoicing when
what was lost is now found amen